I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden returned
to the White House this morning
after spending the weekend at
his beach house in Delaware.
Things must be pretty rough
in Washington
if you think to yourself,
"You know what would be great?
The beach in November."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new pool,
61% of voters approve
of the bipartisan
infrastructure bill,
at least until Biden signs it.
Former President Barack Obama
spoke today at the U.N.
climate summit in Scotland
where he warned that
without immediate action
global temperatures could rise
by as much as two more buttons.
[ Laughter ]
The "Sesame Street" character
Big Bird
announced over the weekend
on social media
that he received
his coronavirus vaccine shot.
"We'll take him!"
said the Packers.
[ Laughter ]
That's good. Good graphic.
It's a good Photoshop.
You wait all day.
I don't see 'em --
I see 'em when you see 'em.
And I'm pretty happy about it.
You know?
According to a new report,
President Biden farted
while speaking to Britain's
Duchess Camilla Parker Bowles
at the U.N. climate summit,
which brings us to a segment
called, "How Is There
Not Video of This?!"
How's there not video of this?
Do you know what kind of
currency that clip would be
for monologue writers?
Think of how many times you've
seen his falling up the stairs.
Now imagine if instead of
falling up the stairs
he was tearin' ass
in front of a royal?
How's there not video of this?
I'd rather not even know
what happened...
than know what happened,
but I'll never see it.
Be like if you just heard about
that news reporter
stomping grapes.
[ Laughter ]
Well.
Maybe that'll cheer me up.
Can we just show that?
-Oh. Oh!
Oh! Ogh-ogh-ogh-ogh!
-Yeah.
Yeah, that helped.
-This has been "How Is There
Not Video of This?!"
-That's right.
Apparently, Britain's
Duchess Camilla Parker Bowles
hasn't been able
to stop talking about
how President Biden let out
a loud, long fart
when they spoke at last week's
U.N. climate summit.
To be fair, he warned her that
he was about to cut methane gas.
[ Laughter ]
Does that mean that's wor--
that she --
I just would have thought
a duchess would have
a different word than "fart."
Learn a new thing every day.
A couple in New Zealand
recently grew a potato
that was about 17 pounds
and named it Doug.
It's what many in New Zealand
are calling
"our top story tonight."
[ Laughter ]
Several inmates
at an Oklahoma jail
recently filed a federal lawsuit
that claims
they had been tortured
by being forced to listen
to the song "Baby Shark"
on repeat for hours.
So if you're wondering
whether we need prison reform,
I'd say we definitely...
♪ Do, do, do,
do-do-do-do-do-do ♪
♪ Do, do, do ♪
[ Laughter ]
Finally, today was
celebrity chef Gordon Ramsey's
55th birthday.
He spent the day
exactly the way he wanted to --
screaming at the person
who baked his cake!
And that was a monologue,
everybody.